One of the reasons I've been telling you that it's
unclear that the Trump riots will have much of an
impact on American politics going forward, is that
many Americans either won't remember what happened
on January 6th or will remember it, but fall for
lies about what it was that took place and believe
something that's a complete fantasy. We now have
evidence that this is happening. There is a new
Reuters Ipsos poll released yesterday which found,
look at this, half of Republicans believe that the
Trump riots were left wing activists merely trying
to make Trump look bad or largely nonviolent
protests. Neither of those assertions is true.
Three in 10 Republicans believe that Trump is
partially responsible for the riots. Seven in 10
do not. 60 percent of Republicans believe that
Donald Trump's believe Trump's lies, that the
twenty twenty election was stolen, 60 percent,
60 percent of Republicans believe that Donald
Trump should run in twenty. Twenty four and
80 percent of Republicans have favorable opinions
of Trump. Many important things to note. No. One,
I said yesterday it would be irresponsible for
a show about American politics to ignore Donald
Trump right now, partially because he still
is the face of the Republican Party. Overall,
this poll again confirms that 60 percent
want him running in three to four years,
three to four years, 80 percent still view
him favorably, 60 percent believe his lies
that he actually was the rightful winner of twenty
twenty. So, again, that is borne out. Number two,
this doesn't suggest that Trump and
Republicans are going to be held accountable
in twenty twenty two, maybe in twenty twenty two.
They will be held accountable for other things,
things that haven't yet happened, things
that will be more fresh and recent in the
minds of Republican voters. But there is
no evidence whatsoever that the Trump riots
and the way that Republicans defended it are going
to. Have any serious impact on twenty twenty to
the voters, either either don't believe it or
they've forgotten or whatever, as I mentioned
very much the party of Trump. They also claim
to be the party of personal responsibility,
but they take no responsibility and assign no
responsibility or blame to their own elected
officials. Ever, ever. I was kind of stepping
back as I was reading these poll numbers and
considering the absurdity of the situation.
Remember that Donald Trump lost the popular vote
by millions in twenty sixteen. He accomplished
essentially zero of his campaign promises.
He was going to pay off the debt. He didn't do
it. He was going to build a wall across the US
Mexico border. He didn't do it. He was going
to replace Obamacare with something beautiful.
He didn't do it. He was going to fix trade. He
didn't do it. I could give you the whole list.
Never had an approval rating, over 50 percent.
The only president in the polling era,
never to reach 50 percent approval, even
on a single day during their presidency.
And then he had the pandemic come in, which
for world leaders that handled it well, was a
ticket to an easy reelection. Trump mismanaged the
pandemic, leading to countless extra unnecessary
deaths. And then Republicans say, oh, clearly,
it's not believable that Trump lost what Trump
did everything wrong, had a disastrous approval
and mismanaged the pandemic. Why would you assume
he's obviously going to win? Why would you assume
Joe Biden somehow stole it? Of course, Trump lost.
And the real shock is. How didn't Trump lose by
more, Trump still almost won electorally, despite
the fact that he mishandled all of those things.
The real tragedy is that despite everything Trump
failed on, seventy five million people still
voted for him. So anybody waiting around for,
you know, the consequences of what the Republican
Party and Trump became and what they did. And
in twenty, twenty two, it's not going to happen.
If they do something disastrous in August of
twenty twenty two, then let's talk. But as I've
said before, Republicans don't even know what's
going on. In general, voters have short political
memories and we're seeing that borne out already.
It's only April of twenty twenty one and more than
half of Republican voters don't even understand
and or refuse to believe what it was that even
happened in January of this year. Let's take
a quick break. Let me know your thoughts about
what could impact the twenty twenty two election.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman. We'll
take a quick break and be right back.
We are a viewer and listener supported program.
Please grab a membership at join Pakman Dotcom.